you
there we go three two tired up as white
again let's do another D for a three-two
er um my opponent is saying that they'll
meet the stream awesome D for Best Buy
test let's go first with my f3 let's see
okay we're gonna have another one of
these we use gambit declined okay let's
see how black plays it they're gonna
probably throw their Bishop here maybe
try to get in a quick fish about five so
these are fun three tours knight c6 okay
so I think this is what I'm gonna do to
try and uh well try and put pressure on
the weakness that's been left behind
here and I don't know that I'm so
concerned with doubled F pawns I could
do this maybe I should have done it
first actually before 97 okay so this is
the structure we're working with and
let's let's develop here I got the
bishop pair no need to rush with
anything queenside castle um maybe hmm
go inside
so yeah okay I'll declare my Kings
intentions right away I don't know if
this is correct but cuz c5 could open up
to okay so notice they're only taking
after my rook has come off of the a file
so we're um we're going about it in a
similar way here let's do this induce
this move so I could do this maybe clamp
down on e5 I only have to be concerned
now about an e5 break maybe let's get
enforced them that move pawn push stop
playing with the two bishops I might
want to try this in b4 b5 they'll never
let me get b5 in though that'll always
be you know put an end to that real
quick with a six hmm efore alright this
was my idea but maybe I could be a bit
more flexible don't want to allow a
static structure maybe efore how am I
not considering efore well for one this
weakens this square here uh let me do
king c2 let's see we're about even on
time let's devote a little bit of
attention here some time here hmm bishop
here maybe let me do this
it's a very modest move I realize but
there might be an idea of stopping
Knight h5 into here if I do in fact play
this move something like e 4 e 4 and
then maybe I get F 4 in not sure it's uh
that's so aggressive it develops it
connects my rooks
I could say it completes my development
neither side as a time and really in
position or really on the clock
pretty even there okay so this was my
idea let's do it
clamp down on this square or they really
do this I might actually do that maybe I
don't want to take the night but rather
kick the night how can I make my
LightSquared bishop a monster you see
they've done really well having nice
harmony with their remaining bishop in
their pawns so these guys are are gonna
be responsible for watching out watching
out for my lights grab a shot
um let's see what more bishops you there
yeah I'm just gonna do with what my
instinct tells me chop back let black
think a little bit do you take me do you
allow me to take you huh
did you anchor your knight in there um
let's improve my King position a little
bit I'd like to see one of these two
pawns move because then this Bishop will
be helped
let's see what I want to do my bishop
here let's do this I'm not sure what
exactly it's doing but I want to maybe
threaten to push this Knight around in
fact there's an ID on the bishop here I
could push and I'm Bishop takes I could
take the knight I don't have to
recapture here my knight would be out of
the line of fire after Bishop takes e1
although we could return and go here mmm
I'm gonna follow suit and make a not so
aggressive move there
maybe rook c1 I have a time edge
I know it's increment but keep some
pressure here in fact let's go back my
knight is just doing nothing there how
could I reposition my knight that's what
I should be looking for let's do this
yeah let's do this so he has to be
careful of f3 with the knight being
trapped this was my idea I'm gonna get
him here I have good control over that
night okay now if I take or if I push
the night huh you know what I don't need
to do that do I if I just take what's
wrong with just taking I'm gonna take
Russia
and improve my night position yeah my
LightSquared bishop needs to do
something maybe I should have done this
50 let's push that night connect my
rooks let's throw a punch at their rook
okay my Knights here to defend that pond
let's see
position let's not I drop my pond let's
do what next let's move him runs the
risk of following night here that's
tough to me in fact I don't know that
you can meet that so well huh this
that's a tough pond to defend okay hmm I
have
this night let's do this
threatening this move um running low on
time
let's take towards the center take here
and now hit f5 maybe they're going to
take with the night now they want to
exchange rooks first hmm maybe that's
not
way to take opposite colored
I am getting this pawn this should be
working
um let's push okay I should be able to
win this because I could fix that pawn
on a light square alright this should be
a win should be let's drop back here
that was very very foolish
stood there I'm ready to drop upon oh
they missed that there's they're being
cut off right there yes and I'll be able
to clean okay they resigned Gigi okay
Gigi
um just a very quick that was a very
very tough struggle interesting
imbalance like really right out of the
gate with then they gave up their Bishop
playing with the bishop pair playing
with the damaged structure you know they
have the perfect harmony between their
remaining bishop in their their pawns
where it really it only got out of
control when we were both down on time I
was fiddling around with this Knight
move yeah I was just fiddling around
with mmm
what am I trying to say when I played
Knight a four I was thinking the bishop
might play here to target this guy so
what did black do he moved his King but
if he did this there's this move and
then at least the knight isn't in
position for like a follow up capture so
I would have this but this isn't we're
really working cuz Bishop here and I'm
dropping III anyhow that was more of
like okay let's make I don't know what
to do exactly let's just kind of make a
passing move in fact these two moves I I
did something that wasn't so meaningful
and black is like well I could do the
same thing just I'll move my king out of
the way and throw the move back on you I
think when my knight got here it started
become a bit critical because he has a
lot of interesting options and if the
bishop is anywhere else but here when my
night is on d3 restricting my Knight as
we saw in the game getting to this
Square and forcing the rook up to an
awkward point to defend that's tricky
pushed I thought around this time my
pawn might fall somehow but never really
got to be the case
interesting interesting struggle finally
pushed and then this is serious so spawn
like this taking is inviting just
another piece on this diagonal got
tricky yeah has mentioned when my night
was on f4 very critical taking with the
night I end up winning upon I don't know
that I played this ending the best way I
think it's all right maybe ah maybe this
is an opportunity for f4 to try and hold
yeah I bet you it is I think this is the
way to draw it at the end where we were
living off of increment in fact I was
going to say well maybe I shouldn't have
done this right away but rather this if
I do this the king will be there in time
to defend this pawn hmm yeah and now you
know maybe he could just shoot right
over and pick him up I think that this
was an opportunity after Bishop here to
play this move to break these guys up
yeah I thought I thought my opponent
would do this and I think if I was
playing his black this would be the the
top move I consider but then I could fix
that guy and then hunt him down I'm
pretty sure this would draw because now
there's only two pawns to deal with so
what would be the drawing if this and
this and this King just comes over like
what would you do I mean just throw your
King right here and have your Bishop go
back and forth on these two squares I
don't think there's really a way you can
stop it yeah there should be some draw
here this is insignificant it's this is
just one pawn I don't think this is
enough Oh
oh maybe this is significant actually I
was just realizing here that I don't
have the correct color bishop to promote
this pawn and was thinking well you
could just black it sacrifices bishop
for one of my f pawns or I was thinking
he could sack it for just my F pond and
then I can't win but this actually does
have some influence in the game
these doubled pawns he did that resource
isn't available to give up the bishop
for one of these and hold the draw with
the wrong color Bishop trying to promote
this guy interesting game this sort of a
problem likely ended in a draw yeah but
this got to be too much and I was
floundering a bit here I should have
done something different what was the
cleaner approach why am I even going in
this direction I should be in a position
to give up my bishop for the pawn if he
becomes a problem I should be going here
or even doing this like right away yeah
like why not like this right away and
then this anyhow he ended up getting
caught behind enemy lines here GG good
game